[Musique]
ne composer jamais avec l'extrémisme le
racisme l'antisémitisme ou le rejet de
l'autre dans notre histoire
l'extrémisme a déjà failli nous conduire
à la bim
c'est un poison il divise il pervertit
il détruit tout dans l'âme de la france
dit non à l'extrémisme
le vrai combat de la france le beau
combat de la france c'est celui de
l'unité c'est celui de la cohésion
oui nos valeurs ont un sens oui la
france est riche de sa diversité
oui l'honneur de la politique c'est
d'agir d'abord pour l'égalité des
chances c'est de permettre à chacun à
chaque jeune d'avoir sa chance ce combat
malgré tous les obstacles et même si je
mesure le chemin qui reste à parcourir
il est désormais bien engagée il doit
nous unir d'hommes la durée c'est l'une
des clés de notre avenir
[Musique]